There are some general factors to
consider when dealing with missing data
and the answers to some
of these questions might
guide us in what methodology
might be the best approach.
For example, one question to consider is
just how much data is really missing?
As we saw from our example, deleting
all the records with any missing data
eliminate a full one-half
of our total data.
This would obviously not
be an acceptable solution.
However, what if we were working
with 10,000 observations and
had missing values in just 200 of them?
Since that means that we could
effectively keep 98% of our records
even after eliminating those missing
data, then in this situation,
distillation method
might be appropriate.
Another question to ask is how
the missing data is distributed across
the dataset?
As we can recall from our example,
we had missing data in
all of our variables.
Whether the majority of what's missing
is in a smaller subset of the variables
available will help guide us
on how to work with them.
An example of this
would be if we had data
with ten different predictor variables.
If most of the missing values were
predominantly in just two of these ten,
then we could deal with them on
a variable by variable basis.
One question to consider would be
whether those specific variables
are actually significant to our
analysis and model making process.
Referring back to our example,
if home ownership wasn't readily
relevant to our business question,
the fact that we have some missing data
for that variable won't really matter.
And in fact,
we might want to just eliminate
that one variable entirely from
consideration for our model and
one further question that we might use
to consider our approach is whether
the variable in question with the
missing data is numeric or categorical.
An example of this from our survey
sample is the education variable.
It's not quite that simple to impute
since coming up with an average
education level might be
a bit more complex, so
this could limit our approach.